our top story the government's
high-stakes debt ceiling negotiations at
a standstill Republican Congressional
leaders walked out of the negotiation
room Friday and warned there will be no
deal without an agreement on Sharp
spending cuts moment at moments after
the walkout former president Trump urged
Republicans to reject a deal and hold
out for everything they want and Wall
Street is closely watching Washington
stocks dipped Friday on the debt ceiling
uncertainty Christina raffini has more
from the White House this morning
Christina good morning
good morning Dana will Republican
negotiators leaving that meeting told
reporters last night they're not
confident a deal can be reached before
default
after walking out of meetings Friday
afternoon
house Republican and White House
negotiators were back at it Friday night
this wasn't a negotiation tonight this
discussion about
realistic numbers a realistic path
forward but that path is anything but
certain we took a pause because of the
frustration that the this white house
will not acknowledge that they're
spending too much appearing on Fox
Business during the afternoon interlude
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
accused President Biden of not listening
to Republican concerns about spending
but for the last 105 days he refused to
negotiate he's not even in the country
today in exchange for raising the debt
limit House Republicans want to cut the
federal budget the equivalent of about
13 percent across the board
talks at home not at all at a meeting
with Australia's prime minister today in
Japan President Biden remained confident
defaults can be avoided first meetings
weren't all that percussive the second
ones were the third one was and then
what happens is the the carriers go back
to the principles and say this is what
we're thinking about and then people put
down new claims I still believe we'll be
able to avoid a default and we'll get
something decent time
now Biden is cutting his trip to Asia
short in order to come back here and try
to hammer out a deal in the next dozen
or so days but even if the two sides
agree to Something in the room that's
not a guarantee that conservatives on
the right or progressives on the left
will even vote for it guys
Christina thank you